hi everyone I'm Kyle Beauchamp I'm a
research fellow at Memorial
sloan-kettering cancer center and today
I want to tell you about our work
building Python tools for biophysical
simulation and to begin I just want to
point out that we've all benefited
handsomely from Moore's law which has
essentially doubled the transistor
counts of micro processors consistently
since the 70s and so we've seen really
transformative improvements in computing
performance over the years and this is a
major benefit for data science and it
makes one wonder is there a similar
trend in medicine or health and you
might ask well is it easier to develop
drugs these days is it cheaper to
develop drugs and I'm afraid to tell you
that the answer is a resounding no if we
look at the number of new drug approvals
from the 1940s to the present we see
that really it's been essentially
constant over the years with a few blips
here and there but overall there's no
over there's no long-term trend for
greater efficiency or more drug
approvals over time you could ask a
similar question and look at how much it
costs to develop a drug and here people
have pointed out industry commentators
for example have pointed out essentially
a reverse Moore's law where over time
it's become increasingly expensive to
develop drugs and cure diseases so in
1950 a billion dollars could essentially
develop about 50 drugs so that much
capital investment could bring 50 drugs
to market and today that same billion
dollars will bear will not even bring a
single drug to market so if you're like
me you'll find this pretty alarming and
quite scary and so in fact if you look
at today's if you look at today's drug
discovery opportunities it costs two
billion dollars to develop a drug it
takes 15 years and it fails essentially
95
% of the time so this is a this is
unfortunate because we don't really have
any better alternatives and so and some
people have even pointed out that if
this trend continues it will no longer
be profitable to cure diseases and so
there will be no investment and no one
will do it anymore what I want to talk
about today is whether computers can
help us to design drugs in a more
perhaps futuristic way so before I begin
I need to give you just a very brief
introduction to some of the science
behind what we're doing and so I want to
introduce some basic concepts from
biophysics so this is a cell it could be
a human cell of bacterial what-have-you
it's I'm just looking at an artist's
rendition and the key point is that this
cell is a bag of protein machines and so
you see the blue blobs the yellow blobs
the orange blobs the blobs are just
machines they do things and when they do
things incorrectly that leads to disease
and so how drugs work is that a drug
typically such as the one shown here in
purple a drug will bind a protein and
essentially help it do its job properly
or prevent it from doing its job
improperly so here I'm looking at a drug
binding to what's called Sark kinase and
this is a protein that's implicated in
human cancer and essentially it tells it
tells cells when to grow and win not to
grow and if obviously if you're growing
too quickly then that's a problem so
this is basically the premise behind a
lot of the things we're doing here where
you have a protein you want to hit it
with a drug so that you can basically
tell the protein to behave properly so
this leads us to a few questions in
these challenges in molecular medicine
medicine are can be linked this nano
scale biophysics with human disease and
can we use this knowledge to engineer
drugs that bind protein
and achieve some sort of therapeutic
action and so what I want you to notice
is it both of these challenges here are
challenges that happen at the nano scale
at the length scale of atoms and
molecules and proteins and so that's the
link scale at which we want to do our
complete use computation to approach
these problems so the technology behind
everything I'm talking about today is a
computer simulation technique known as
molecular dynamics where we used
physics-based simulations of
biomolecules and it's going to look
something like this where we're going to
essentially use the same physics you
learned in college to simulate a protein
such as the one shown here in white and
simulate a drug perhaps a drug binding
to the protein and so this actually this
movie comes from researchers in New York
City actually at DE Shaw research but
the key idea is that we're going to try
and simulate the physics of these
nanoscale machines and use it to design
drugs that help help them do their jobs
better so today I want to talk to you
more about the software behind what
we're doing and so what I haven't told
you yet is that the kinds of simulations
that I've talked about are extremely
challenging computationally and so the
protein that I showed you if you want to
simulate that protein in a bot in a bath
of water which is where it naturally
will live is basically we're looking at
a system with 10 to the five atoms
hundreds of thousands of atoms and
what's even worse is that we're
interested in simulating biologically or
medically relevant processes and so
these processes occur on the second time
scale the millisecond time scale or the
micro second time scale but because of
hard physical constraints and how we run
these simulations we have to simulate
things essentially one femtosecond at a
time and so we're talking about spanning
essentially perhaps 15 orders of
magnitude using computers and that we
need to repeat an iteration of our
simulation 10 to the 5th
almost 10 to the 15 times so obviously
this is a grand computational challenge
and what we've developed is a library
called open mmm and this is work from
colleagues at Stanford led by Peter
Eastman and Vijay Pandey others and
others but we have developed a GPU
accelerated molecular dynamics library
that is a C++ library with python
bindings and actually a number of other
bindings but we provide hardware
backends for CUDA opencl and CPU
platforms and the end result is that we
can simulate with a modern GPU
essentially 100 nanoseconds per day and
that's 10 to the minus 7 seconds and so
that brings us about halfway to the time
skills that I was telling you that we
needed to reach to actually make an
impact in disease so we went from 10 to
the minus 10 to the minus 15 seconds to
10 to the minus 7 seconds and we're
still a long ways away and so another
technology is that we are deploying the
this GPU accelerated dynamics engine
unfolding at home which is the world's
largest distributed computing project
and so with building at home we have
access to hundreds of thousands of CPUs
tens of thousands of GPUs and
essentially 40 petaflops of peak
performance and so we are simulating
hundreds of microseconds per day now
using this resource and the donors that
provide access to their GPUs and because
of this many people have published a
number of research papers all in
biophysics based on results from this
supercomputer so what you might wonder
is what kind of are there any data
challenges associated with generating
this huge amount of data the answer is
yes and so more colleagues at Stanford
led by Robert mcgibbon have developed a
library for doing trajectory io on the
output of these simulations and so
there's a library that we've developed
called md trash which is a python
library for reading and writing the
trajectory objects or essentially the
movies that come out from these
simulations and so we read a wide number
of formats and we can perform arbitrary
geometric analyses calculating things
like distances angles root mean squared
deviations and these calculations are
kind of the standard bread-and-butter
ways that people look at protein
structure and dynamics furthermore we've
optimized our code using numpy and SSE
where appropriate to really scale things
up to the full level necessary to
analyze folding at home data sets so for
example this is just an example of the
pythonic API you import the library you
load a trajectory object what you get
back is just a trajectory object and
then you call some analysis function on
that object and here I'm plotting
essentially a time trace of some
geometric quantity during the course of
the movie or the trajectory object that
you get back and so we've also built
this into the ipython notebook so that
we can visualize the three-dimensional
structures of proteins as a function of
time and so I'm not going to go into a
full tutorial today but I'm just going
to say that we have a ipython notebook
widget what uses WebGL and a viewer for
proteins and you can actually use that
to kind of psyched to watch proteins
wiggle in your trajectory data so
another challenge that we face is that
it's not enough to just generate a movie
and calculate some structural property
we really need to find meaning in these
massive simulation data sets and finding
meaning it's essentially the same sort
of challenge that data scientists face
in a number of disciplines and so we
have developed a set of tools called MSM
builder and mixtape and these tools
allow us to essentially build machine
learning models to understand the
dynamics of proteins from our simulation
data
to put this in a little better
perspective here is an example of an
output model from our software pipeline
the idea is that we want to understand
how a protein changes shape over time
and to do this we're going to build a
network model of the protein so here
we're looking at how the protein goes
from an unfolded state to a
well-structured folded state and we
build a what's called a markov state
model it's similar to a hidden markov
model which many of you have probably
used as a standard routine tool in data
science but the idea is that the protein
is wiggling and jiggling and you treat
that process as a jumping process
between discrete States or essentially a
network like model so with this
capability we're currently in the
process of developing our next
generation of this software and one of
the key ideas that we're pushing is a
timer integration with the wider Python
data science community and what we mean
by this is that our next release which
we're calling we're code naming the next
release mixtape right now but it's just
a code name for the third release of MSM
builder but what we're really pushing
for is something that's SK learn
compatible so that we can plug and play
with kind of the industry standard
machine learning tools that are
available to people and so just to give
you a feel for what this means we import
a bunch of modules we fetch our data
from the cloud we generate a list of
trajectory objects from the data set we
instantiate a few objects and we plug
them together into a pipeline which is a
standard way of working with SK learn as
you pipeline different models together
and then you fit those that pipeline
model onto your data which in our case
is a set of trajectories but this
pipeline sort of mentality is basic is
basically a key component of how SK
learn works and we're trying to make our
tools kind of plug and play compatible
so to change gears a little bit i also
want to talk about some of the work
going on at
memorial sloan-kettering and we are
currently developing a tool called yank
which is a tool for fast fast
calculations of binding affinity of
drugs and proteins and it's fast because
we're essentially using some tricks from
statistical mechanics where we're
essentially letting the drug which is
the yellow molecule we're letting it
vanish and so it basically becomes
invisible to the protein it turns out
that this is a very clever and efficient
way to cut to estimate the binding
affinity or how tightly this drug into
binds of protein and so by using tricks
like this we can dramatically accelerate
how quickly we can calculate binding
affinities and so this is the basis for
this software package that we're
currently on route to have a release in
the near future I want to change gears
one more time and talk a little bit
about the difficulties in developing and
releasing scientific software in Python
and so feel free to interrupt me if
people want have questions but a few
weeks ago I had a user come to me and he
told me that I like I couldn't install
your module like he said oh there's just
no I just couldn't figure it out I used
easy install and it just didn't work for
me and well I thought easy install
worked but obviously it didn't work for
him and this is actually a pretty common
sort of thing in scientific computing
and that people have difficulty getting
the whole whole pipeline up and running
getting the whole stack up and running
and I actually probably get some sort of
issue like this maybe once every two
months or something depending on which
library we're talking about but um and
if you if i look back to my own history
when i started my PhD in 2008 i had to
build basically everything from source i
had to build numpy syfy and it was a
major challenge and so here i'm showing
you a graph of the dependencies of our
various software packages yank and open
a member on the right and obviously they
all depend on numpy and scifi the nodes
that are read or things that I consider
hard to build
if you have to do it from scratch and so
basically in 2008 everything was hard
eventually things like em fat Python
came around and things got a little bit
easier and that it was easy to get numpy
and scifi up and running and so so it
became easy to get numpy sigh pine
netcdf but there were still a few things
that are still pretty challenging so
things like cuda see bake they generally
had pretty strong version dependencies
and we're just not always pleasant to
get up and running I'm going to tell you
shortly but today I think we're pretty
close to having things almost fully
automated and that we're using Conda to
deploy pretty much everything and it's
becoming a much more pleasant experience
getting things up and running and so one
of the one of the potential pitfalls
that a lot of people run into is what's
known as G lib see how where you build
your libraries on a modern computer and
then you want to send them off to your
friend who has a sysadmin who insists on
using an ancient version of Linux and
they can't use they can't use the
libraries that you built but you don't
want to downgrade your system to make
something that works on his system it
turns out we've pretty much solved the
problem now by picking a sweet spot of
CentOS 6.6 where we provision a vagrant
virtual machine and build all of our
recipes on centos 6.6 and we've got this
kind of automated and we have the
virtual machine on github now or at
least the provisioning script and so we
basically automated the process of
making binary or making libraries that
run on pretty much all the hardware that
we've come in our hardware and software
that we've come into contact with and I
am happy to say that by using this
pipeline the same user that came to me
complaining is actually up and running
now just by using a condom based install
so I think we're we're making progress
in getting things into users hands so
that scientists can do the science and
not focus on building libraries all day
so now and what's more is that now we
are in
in progress we are developing a feta
package for installing our entire suite
of computational tools so the entire
suite for simulation data munging model
building visualization we want to be
able to install all of these tools with
a one-liner and I actually have a alpha
version of that one liner up and running
it's not we're probably another few
weeks from having an actual full-fledged
beta release but a lot of the work is
done and so it's actually this work this
sort of thing works where you can
install the entire suite of software
tools with a one-liner dependencies are
handled automatically and so it seems to
be a pretty reasonable sort of approach
when the change gears one last time and
talk about how we might use these models
and falsify them in the wet lab so I've
told you about a lot of computational
models but models are really useless if
you have no way to validate them to
falsify them or refine them and and this
sort of validation occurs by making real
measurements in the wet lab but that's
really expensive so chemistry and bio
chemistry biology and physics they're
really labor-intensive things to do and
we're talking about models with
thousands of parameters which means you
probably need to be making thousands of
measurements so we have a really massive
challenge with reproducibility and
scalability so work in the Kidero lab
and this is work from yon Hendrik Prince
bas rustenburg Sonia Hansen they've been
developing software libraries to make
experiments as easy as programming in
Python so the idea is that you can
import some modules you can instantiate
some classes and kind of string them
together to actually perform experiments
in the wet lab and these experiments are
going to be performed on a robot that
looks something like this
but this is actually building the robot
that we have at memorial sloan-kettering
what no no they're just fast forwarded I
cannot
alright so yeah that's basically our the
robot that we're using and see sorry
about the volume but it was my poor
little macbook air speakers but just to
leave you I just want to give you our
vision for what biophysical modeling and
experiment should be and that we really
want it to be reproducible automated
testable and really just useful for
making predictions and testing them and
with that I just want to thank all the
people who did the work my boss John
Coderre collaborators at Stanford
particularly Robert McKibben Peter
Eastman Vijay Pandey collaborators or
colleagues at mskcc Stanford Rutgers and
elsewhere and thank you for your
attention any questions yes so it's
going to depend on exactly exactly what
experiment we're doing but so the
binding experiment is going to be
basically we're going to be doing
high-throughput binding experiments on
the robot basically similar to the model
or the video of the ligand wiggling and
binding the protein we calculate the
binding affinity and then we compare
that to experiment and my labmate sonya
there is actually the one doing those
experiments but so the idea is really
automate and really make it high
throughput and hopefully not painful to
do so
um we actually have a buffer maker that
we are so we could do two things we
could actually the robot itself has a
liquid handler on it and we also have
another robotic buffer maker what's it
called its called a revo it's from a
start-up in Boston lab mines and it's
like a giant it looks like a giant
vacuum cleaner or something it's like as
big as a refrigerator and it just makes
buffer in an automated way and they have
like a pretty cool iphone app and it's
all web based and you know on the cloud
yeah it's a it really wants to use all
your flops and once you know
particularly if you have a GPU it will
it will definitely eat up the GPU and as
many courses right right yeah yeah oh
thank you